continuing our uh sort of tour of the
news here
um it is now time for new york governor
andrew cuomo to resign uh i that
that is my view joe biden said the same
yesterday
and many others as well um he has been
now accused and investigated
for uh sexually harassing multiple women
we now have the results of an
investigation cnbc
summarizes it new york governor andrew
cuomo sexually harassed multiple women
who worked for the state and elsewhere
according to a report by state attorney
general leticia james
the investigation concluded cuomo quote
violated federal and state law
james said at a press conference cuomo
then retaliated against a former
employee who complained publicly about
his conduct according to the report
the probe into numerous women's
allegations of sexual harassment by
cuomo started in march
after the state's executive chamber
granted james's request
to investigate further coverage of this
albany d.a criminally investigating
cuomo asks any victim of new york
governor sexual harassment
to contact office the d.a of albany
county
said his office is criminally
investigating cuomo
d.a david soares said his office would
welcome any victim to contact our office
with additional information about cuomo
source said he plans to request
investigative materials from the state
attorney general's probe
of the alleged harassment of 11 women so
listen for people who were saying oh
david you partisan chill and you'll
but no hold on guys we're we're going to
have the same
standard here for left and right earlier
there were allegations and an
investigation started and at that time i
said let's see what the investigation
finds
we now have an investigation that
appears to have been done without
obvious political bias of some kind
where the investigation's results would
not be trustworthy so although
there have not been criminal charges
here the investigation is credible
and this in my view now encumbers andrew
cuomo's ability to just be the governor
to such a degree
that i believe it is time for him to
resign
um i i don't find myself
even needing to say much more about it
it's just time for him to resign
now interestingly um he put out
an 85 85 page written response
there's only 26 pages of text and a lot
of the pages are just
pictures of andrew cuomo in various
types of embrace with different figures
including joe biden um with
his mom matilda cuomo with hurricane
victim
sandra patterson it's basically oh i'm
sorry this is an example of george w
bush embracing hurricane victim sandra
patterson sort of saying
listen this type of hugging is not
a big deal lots of people do it here's
barack obama
hugging hillary clinton it's really just
not a big deal
also taking the approach in a video that
he put out
of just saying this is how i interact
with people
i just hug people there's nothing
inappropriate about it which is
it's sort of like an affirmative defense
he's not denying the contact with the
women he's just saying
this is no big deal i do it with
everyone
right black and white young
and old straight
and lgbtq powerful people
friends strangers
people who i meet on the street so
i think it's an interesting approach i
don't think andrew cuomo survives this
and he should resign at this time if you
disagree with me
let me know i would love to hear from
you
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part
of it could be because of the blue light
coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that
blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin
which can make it difficult to fall
asleep blue light can disturb your
circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks
glasses which filter out that blue light
they're one of our sponsors
a lot of other companies are mass
producing supposed blue light glasses
and factories with no actual quality
standards
blue blocks glasses are made in actual
optics labs
at their headquarters in australia they
have over 40 stylish frames
a prescription version non-prescription
even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks sells
they give a pair of reading glasses to
someone in need
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to blue blocks dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video
and there's free shipping worldwide
on orders over 115 dollars